[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
whose mother is living in her car and
she wants to know how to set boundaries
we also talked to a father who's lost
faith in his teenage daughter and
spoiler alert everybody
we're all gonna die stay tuned
[Music]
what up what up what up
this is john with the dr john dolone's
show
so glad you're with us
talking about mental health your
relationships being well
living in this chaotic crazy mess of a
world
[Music]
uh
van halen referenced today earlier in a
segment me and
jimmy charles were doing
missed it
i i mean every time i think we're
getting closer and closer together james
so close sorry i wasn't born in the
70s or whenever you were born
sorry i didn't oh yeah
kelly was born in the 40s dude back it
off
dude your hair the person who dyes your
hair does an incredible job like most
people can't tell unless you're really
close all right
and
let's go let's go to liz in maui hey liz
what's up
hi dr john thanks for taking my call
thank you for calling what's happening
i just want to let you know this call
could go south at any minute i've got a
two-year-old a three-year-old and a
four-year-old home all home quarantining
wow
[Laughter]
we could just stop the call right there
and
how about this
i have a great idea you take the phone
and just go to sleep and just put it by
your head and that way your kids may not
bother you for a second and i'll just
sit here in silence and we'll just take
10 minutes for you the whole country
will just sit with you wow it's a lot
hey no problem moment of silence yes so
what's up
uh so
uh my issue today you know i got a lot
of them but one for today
um
my mother-in-law was living with us for
an amount of time and then a
old boyfriend came back into her
into her life and she decided to go
and
live with him in her car on the beach
which is what we call homeless in hawaii
actually um this is a i learned this in
grad school that's actually homeless
everywhere in all of all of earth oliver
well i guess when it's on the beach in
hawaii it seems a little bit oh more
romantic
um so which was fine her choice her life
she's you know a six-year-old adult she
can do what she wants
but
the relationship has been
uh abusive
and she has come back
twice
like left him came back lived with us
and the second time she brought bedbugs
with her
oh
those are the worst
yeah did you get them
yes oh gosh i i for years i was over
residence halls at universities and dude
kids would bring those this is called
ugh they're the worst and they don't
ever go away you have to just
burn your house down and rebuild
a new one
not really but yeah they're the worst
i'm sorry that's terr that's tough
it's just constant cleaning and spraying
and hey at least you don't have three
little kids that could get bed bugs too
oh man what a mess what a mess
so how can i help
so
that was kind of like
the last draw almost we you know we took
that risk we knew that she had the bed
bugs in her car
got her car treated
did everything you know precaution wise
we could to keep the bed bugs out
um got him anyways but that was a risk
that we took and it was like you know
mom for you to have a safe place like
that's fine
you know we'll take that risk we'll deal
with it together
but
then she went back
to the exact same place where she was
with the same guy
and
um now she's been reaching out like she
misses the kids
right now we're in quarantine anyways so
don't really need to respond to her yet
but
um
i don't know how to respectfully and
with dignity
tell her like hey you know we can't be
your safe landing place
you know when you're putting our family
at risk every time yeah
that one's hard
what's your what's your husband how is
he handling this
um well he just doesn't uh he just
doesn't deal with it
[Music]
him and his mom have uh this isn't new
to him okay uh her choosing
a boyfriend or herself over
over family
so that's been his
story his whole life
so a question i have
for her
have you all sat down and given her very
clear boundaries
um
and here's what here's what i'm getting
at here's what i'm getting at
i often find myself blaming somebody
for the way that they interact with me
without taking full ownership
that i am responsible for the way i
allow people to treat me and my family
if i haven't said if this happens
this is the consequence you think we
think we don't have to do that with
adults and it would be a perfect world
if we didn't but we do it's just reality
so have you all sat down and said
if you bring home a disease if you bring
home bugs if you come here intoxicated
if you come here on drugs or high you
cannot be a part of this house
we'll love you and see you out on the
beach for hot dogs but you are not
welcome here have you all sat down and
been that clear with her
um no we haven't and i guess part of the
thing is
um
we've been helping out family a lot
lately and we're just we're just kind of
done with it like we just want everybody
to take care of themselves
and wouldn't that be so nice oh yeah and
you could just leave
and what's ironic about what you're
saying is
you just want to deal with your five and
four and three-year-old right and your
husband and which is
an
unbelievable amount of work anyway
um
back to the boundary conversation
have you had this conversation with your
husband
or are you speaking in we in the plural
because it helps prop you up
because it sounds to me like you were
all
freaking alone
if it was up to my husband he just would
not talk to her not deal with her
okay at all unless she like showed up to
the house okay so he's done done with
her
yeah he's just over it okay
but i know she's also my kid's
grandmother
and she's been messaging me that she
wants to see them that she misses us
and
um
[Music]
yeah and that's hard especially if my
husband's just like oh i'm done i'm just
not doing it so here's what's got to
happen you and your husband have to have
a hard conversation i know you got three
little kids
and it's gonna have to be after they go
to bed or they're taking naps or
something somebody's gonna come over and
watch them and you all gotta have a hard
conversation
and here's the two parts to your
conversation number one it's
what is our boundaries
when it comes to mom
are we serious if she shows up in the
middle of the night
are we gonna not let her in
or yes we'll let her in when she comes
but only when she knocks on the door and
all right so what are our boundaries
however hard they are
the second part of this conversation has
to be your or what moment
if she comes banging on the door to 11
o'clock looking for a place to sleep are
y'all gonna call the cops on her if she
won't leave
like what is your or what how far does
these how how willing are you to hold
these boundaries
and then
the right thing i believe because we're
not talking about she's not abusive
she's not um
she's bringing chaos to you but it's
it's secondhand chaos right
i think the right thing to do is when
you and your husband come to agreement
you'll shake on this y'all kiss on this
you all bump four heads together i don't
know whatever y'all do right you all say
this is in stone
we agree on this
and i think for the first time you need
to be open and honest with him about how
you feel about how he's responding how
your your mother-in-law's response
you all need to bring mother-in-law into
this and have a conversation and hand it
to her in writing too
so that she knows we love you
and part of your boundary may be you are
welcome to live with us but you cannot
see this man anymore
you're welcome to live with us but if
you live here you're here
and if you're going to live under
talk about
flipping the rules around if you're
gonna live under our roof it's our rules
right and if you're not
we respect your right to sleep on the
beach with some abusive wackadoo if
you'd like to
we will not participate that in that and
we will not have our kids around that
and ultimately she will say so you're
telling me i got to choose between this
and this yes
because we're making adult decisions now
with our boundaries
and hear me say liz
this will be the hardest thing you ever
do it's hard
hard heart not the hardest thing you
ever do i can tell you've been through
some stuff this will be hard
and any other family members you have
same thing same level of boundaries so
when i say that out loud how does that
sound
um i mean
we're both
veterans we're used to confrontation
it's not something that we shy away from
i think it's just
finding that middle ground of
um you know while she's making the
choice
to
stay with this guy who is not good for
her
you know
but then am i enabling her by telling
her that she's always got a safe place
um she's always got somewhere to fall i
mean yeah y'all are
y'all are the safety net where she goes
walking on a tightrope
and i don't know that that's a bad thing
it's gonna get very confusing for your
your kids
yes and
i don't i i couldn't let my mom just sit
on the front porch
you know what i mean
but also i'm thinking of my mom and
she's not an addict and she
makes good decisions right so it's
different
yes
but i also have known families that have
said you can't come into the house for
addiction issues for violence issue
whatever and it was 1 000 the right
thing
what's holding you back from pulling the
trigger on this
um
what do you think's going to happen
i guess part of it too is that it's not
my mom like if it was my mom i would be
i would go there and kick her butt and
drag her
by her hair
but uh my mom wouldn't be in that
situation yeah
so that it's not my own mother
my mother-in-law and then i'm just
trying to show her
um respect
and
just just find the right words to
theater like you know hey let's meet up
at the park with the kids and you can
see them then so but you're not coming
to my house there you go while you're
dating this fool right and
you're trying to respect her
and she is not respecting her grandkids
she's not respecting her son she's not
respecting you
and i'm not saying that's licensed to
not be respectful i don't think so i
think that's the problem in the world
it's like oh you're not respecting you
then i'm not respecting you and then we
all act like three-year-olds
that's not the point but you do you have
a responsibility to respect yourself
and respect your husband and respect the
boundaries of your home and your kids
and allowing this mess in your home
sounds like
it's
disrespectful
and i love the idea i love that you
found an alternative you found a middle
ground which is
if you want to see the kids you can see
them we'll meet you at the park we go to
the park every thursday at three o'clock
you are welcome to join us there we'd
love to see you there
and that's the boundary we're drawing
that's hard
but it sounds to me like it's right does
it sound right to you
it does good i guess just the issue is
you know with her bouncing back and
forth
yeah i i mean
again you said it when you at the
beginning of the call she's 60. she can
do what you're going to do
it's you and your husband saying what
are we going to tolerate in our home
we're not going to accept the toggling
back and forth
or you get one shot at our house and
then when you leave we are assuming that
you are choosing him over us you're
allowed to do that good for you here's
our boundaries because we want our kids
to have that stability we want our kids
to have that openness we want our kids
to have that
um firm foundation of relationships
it's hard
and maybe there's a part of you
that looks at your husband and says
get down on the beach
and get your mom and tell her to come
home
and if you feel that way about him
if you feel like he's not stepping up to
the plate in the same way you would
not in a mean way not an ugly way
nothing uh i taught
tell him
go get your mom
go get your mom and she's 60 she can do
what she wants
but man there's something about
something about that lost
sheep i'm gonna go get you and bring you
home we'll be right back on the dr john
de luna show
research has shown that the food you eat
directly impacts your mental and
physical health and that's why i'm a
maniac about putting good food into my
body and my family's body but we all
know that good food is super expensive
and when was the last time you went to a
butcher shop but my friends at
greensbury have solved it all greensbury
is a direct to consumer usda grade
organic meat provider right now they're
putting together a john doloni starter
pack filled with my favorite cuts how
crazy is that rib eye steaks ground beef
chicken breast pork chops bacon salmon
you got it go to
greensbury.com to get 10 off your
starter pack sent to your door today
all right we are back
it is own your past change of future
week month year i don't know is is it i
feel like i can declare a day now right
own your past change your future day
it's in pre-sale please go pick this
book up you can click a link i bet
around here somewhere i bet there's a
link on this
show on the internets or you can go to
johndaloney.com check it out it's 20
bucks you get tons of free stuff with
this thing including a free month of
counseling some of you after you read
this book you might think yeah i should
probably go talk to somebody i took care
of that for you better help stepped up
and we've got you go check it out own
your past change your future
i'm proud of this thing
i'm proud of this thing i think we're
going to help some folks let's go to
aaron in
st louis missouri what's up aaron
hey uh not much how are you doing today
good brother how are you
i'm doing okay doing all right uh-oh
what's going on man yeah it should be
doing better um
i'm trying to figure out how to
move forward and
like trust my
very young teenage daughter again after
some really poor
choices on her part
whatever
well
she
she has done some vaping and then she
uh
we woke up in the middle of the night
and realized she had snuck out of the
house oh no where'd she go
uh
well you know
she had a boy come pick her and some
friends up
uh they went to ihop and then they ended
up at that boy's house and there's a
large age i mean she's 13 and he's 17.
whoa
yeah
no bueno on that one
no
uh and she has a she had a secret burner
phone
some big trust violations what was on
the phone
um snapchat
all the stuff she didn't want us knowing
about we have bark on her real phone
um the app bark so that you can you know
be safe
but when you when you say snapchat is
she sending photos of herself out and
about
uh not really photos just
texting with
you know lots of people people she
doesn't even know okay
but we couldn't find any evidence of
photos okay is it is it sexualized
texting or is it just
people i love it yeah okay all right
okay
real
so how can i help man i'm
sorry well
we're we're trying to figure out how to
move forward like
like i want her to have a good life and
fun and
be safe and i just i need to know how i
can learn to trust her again and what
what we can do
man
so
let me address the the first thing you
said first
i snuck out a lot as a kid
now not from my house cause i my dad was
a swat hostage negotiator and a homicide
detective there was no sneaking out of
that home it was a fortress right
i remember one time i went to the
bathroom like i had socks on or
something and i went to the bathroom i
came out and my dad's just standing
there in the hallway and i was like whoa
you know i mean so there was but
buddy's houses i mean we ran the streets
and we weren't bad we were always
wrapping people's houses toilet paper
causing just we're just being idiots
um
and so here's what i want to tell you
experimenting trying things out it
it's easy to go i just want my daughter
to have a good life
and so i want you to know like man i got
a good life i don't i i make good
choices now right so i want you to think
all is lost because you have a 13 year
old that's trying to experience the
world
the the loss of trust though is
devastating so walk me backwards how
long has she been pressing on things
the way you're talking this sounds like
a total shock to you is this a true
total shock or have you seen some stuff
coming
and it just kept building and building
like what's your daughter trying to say
to you guys
um
so
i i think it's more of a more of a shock
um we we did have an incident maybe a
year ago where she met someone online
and that's what
prompted us to install bark on her phone
and since then i thought things were
kind of on the right path
and then
middle of the night she's not in her
room and we're calling the police and
panicked and
what's her response been in all this
um
so
like
every every single thing that's come out
we've had to dig it out she's toned up
she's to nothing
and she'll always say this is the last
thing i promise i promise i've done
nothing else wrong and then
like
you know
her group of friends
that were in on this with her like all
the moms are
like detective level smart they're going
through every single
piece of the their lives to figure this
out and so every time
you know we figure something out and
then a couple days later another big
thing comes out and then another big
thing comes out and
um
so
it's it feels like it's worse and worse
and it just doesn't it doesn't end
are you still waiting for another shoe
to drop
yes
what do you think is out there
i
don't know
nothing yes i
don't know because there's
there just seems to be more out there
okay
um this is a hard question that i ask
every parent in this situation
where is she picking up some of this
stuff
and when i say some of this stuff i'm
talking about the idea of keeping
secrets the idea of somebody else needs
to
help me feel valued and seen
i need that
burning in my chest i need that
sensation that i'm walking in danger
um where has she learned that
i
think
i mean it's not all
her friends but you know her closest
friend is probably
two years older than her almost
maybe a year and a half older than her
and i you know she's just she's kind of
in a different phase maybe at this age
so i think some of it's that and
maybe
i don't know some of the shows she
watches on netflix or whatever
i'm just not sure how's your
relationship with her how's your wife's
relationship with her how's your
marriage
um our
i would say our marriage is really good
um and
i
try to have a close relationship with
her
but it's really hard right now because
she everything that we used to do that
was fun is now stupid and don't want to
do that and
i've tried hard to do things with her
and like the only
the only two things that she will really
do with me anymore is uh she likes to
make banana bread so we make banana
bread together and we go grocery
shopping together
but it's super hard we used to play card
games and board games and
like do all types of things and now it's
that's not what she wants to do she
wants to talk on the phone to her
friends or sure
stuff like that and that's part of
growing up sure so
how's your relationship with your wife
with her mom
um i think it's pretty
i think it's okay
so
like
maybe some headbutting there well yeah
some of that's natural but
there's some there's a disconnect here
okay there's a disconnect
if it's
it's good it's okay
there is a conversation about
like there's an openness i can talk to
you about things
there's something that she's picked up
in the environment that says we don't
talk about this in this house
this isn't a safe place to discuss these
things
whatever these things happen to be
i need to go get that sort of
interaction from other people
now like experimenting with vaping is
like that doesn't make me lose one
second of sleep that's being a kid
and is it safe no is it smart no is it
dumb yes is it the end of no i mean like
the kids are gonna try stuff out that's
why parents are there for boundaries
um
but there's something about there's a
wedge in the relationship and i don't
want to blame you and your wife that's
not what i'm doing but i want you to be
honest with your the ecosystem in your
house
it sounds like the way you describe it
again it there's i know it's nervous
calling the show and i'm trying to pick
up on little cues from your voice here
and some of it's just me shooting in the
dark but
it sounds like you're hurt
that she doesn't want to hang out with
you anymore or doesn't want to do the
old things y'all used to do like that
gets in your heart a little bit
and what i would challenge you to do is
not give permission for a 13 year old to
hurt you
because she's 13. she's a kid he's a
child she's experimenting right now some
things you told me she likes to do with
you
sounds like she's practicing being an
adult which is which if i think of it in
those ways that's awesome so i'm gonna
start thinking
i'm gonna mourn i'm gonna grieve the
fact that she don't play cards with me
or do i wanna play video games whatever
i used to do
and now i'm gonna think of ways what are
things we can practice doing as adults
together like what are some of those
kind of right and there's just that
natural distance that a 13 year old a 14
year old a 16 year old an 18 year old is
just gonna feel from their parents and
that hurts
but if a kid feels like they are
responsible
for the emotional well-being of their
parents
for the emotional stability of a house
they'll crumble under that weight
and so what i would love to see man i'd
love to see you and your wife get really
clear on what boundaries you're gonna be
i'll tell you in my house this is gonna
sound draconian and i'm gonna get mean
internet letters about it and i don't
care
in my house if this same thing happens
i am
there is no there will be no phones zero
none
there will not be an internet connection
there won't be social media that stuff's
gone
gone
the access to 17 year olds and 18 year
olds and 28 year olds and 30 year olds
is too great
and your daughter's shown
that holding this tool
that she's not capable of you wouldn't
hand her a chainsaw and just say you
just be careful with this thing honey
you wouldn't do that the phones are gone
gone
and i'm gonna set up some put some ways
after some appropriate punishment yadda
yadda whatever
i'm gonna set up some ways that she can
be in connection with her friends just
gonna be on our terms
i'm gonna be there with you we're all
going to the concert but i'm driving and
i'm sitting there with y'all
or you are choosing to not do anything
with your friends
and she's gonna make it all oh my gosh
you're ruining everything huh
she has to understand and she doesn't
yet because she's still not coming clean
she's still not telling the truth
she still doesn't feel safe to speak out
loud for some reason whatever reason
um
she has to understand the weight of that
consequence and
talking a lot to 13 year olds doesn't
usually work
because they're 13.
they have to live it and experience it
and it's hard and it's painful on
everybody and it'd be easier if you just
give her a phone and send her back to
school
um so my house it would be off i would
be spend the next two weeks four weeks
six weeks
you will spend time with us
you'll be out of your room you're going
to be doing your homework in the in the
family room we're all going to be here
together and i'm going to have to alter
my life my wife's going to have to alter
her life the other kids are going to
alter their lives because we're going to
get in this thing together
and at the same time if you disconnect
her from her
community her friends her 13 year old
friends at school
to a 13 year old brain that will feel
like she's drowning
that would be a a trauma that would be a
terror right and so it's a weird balance
you're gonna have to find here
one thing i might recommend ma'am is
she may not want to talk to you
she may feel scared to tell for whatever
reason
i would recommend
getting a
journal that y'all share together that
you write in and then it stays on her
bed she writes in it and puts it back on
your bed and if it's not there in the
next morning or the next evening then
she is choosing some sort of consequence
that you all agree on
um have you
sat down with her or your wife sat down
with her and talked about some dumb
things y'all did when you were kids some
things y'all wish y'all could take back
yes okay how does that land with her
i she kind of i mean i thought it landed
well actually
um
like
you know i told her
i did some of the things she did right
and i told her about it um with some of
the consequences or
how that worked out for us
i thought that landed better than some
of the
other conversations we've had
there's something about humanizing a
parent
not just as a power dynamic and as a
rule thought maker and a rule follower
like oh you were 13 too that doesn't
always work but there's something that
is connective about that right there's
there's some connectivity
i i wish i had a nicer way to say this
okay aaron
there's gonna have to be a moment where
you don't take this personally
this violation of trust wasn't an attack
on aaron
this feels like that right now and your
feelings are running hot
but i want you to step away from she's
doing this to us
and look at it as she is practicing to
be an adult she's trying to make adult
decisions she's leaning into things she
was given access by you and your wife
to the whole wide world and the whole
wide world said well welcome 13 year old
we'd love to have you
and everybody went
i
i would be highly concerned about photos
floating around out there
and if there's even a remote hint of
that
you got to hop on that one quick man and
if people got to go to jail they got to
go to jail if there's people who are
not minors i mean
you you know i'm going there and i know
that's unbelievable to think about your
13 year old but that's where we're at
i want to see you open up some sort of
communication usually writing works if
talking won't
and some back and forth communication
that begins to slowly
that space that frozen ice between the
two of you between you and her and your
wife and i want you and your wife to
take an honest look at the household
ecosystem have we created a space that
we have all the answers this is just the
way this right is there a dialogue in
this house have we made it unsafe for
people to talk and it may be that you
sit down with your daughter and say
i think i've made it
unsafe for you to speak to me to talk to
me to tell me the truth
have i done that
what does it feel like when you when i
ask you if you've done something and you
don't tell it like tell me what you're
feeling
why why you feel unsafe to tell me the
truth even when you've done something
dumb
go that route with it instead of i can't
believe you lied we'll get to the
dishonesty we all know that's wrong
but i want you to connect with your your
daughter the best you can at a human
level
and let her know that you're on her team
you're on her side this isn't you versus
her
there is going to be some really hard
consequences some uncomfortable
consequences but that you're with her
and for her not against her i know
that's hard man i know it's hard
thanks for the call brother
it's not personal she's 13. it's not
personal we'll be right back
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back so
um somebody sent me this article and i
just wanted to stop the presses for a
minute
um i talk about this directly in
my new book and this is something that
has been on my soul for a long time and
as you all know i've spent a lot of
years walking alongside people who have
lost others
and
we have not done a good job as a society
as a culture as as a group of just
people this group of humans trying to
make do on this planet
dealing with
what i think is one of the more
important existential um clouds that
hang over us and that is this
uncomfortable truth
that you and me and all of us
are going to pass away
and we live in a culture now that
we sanitize over it we wallpaper over
death and even get this
like we've talked about on the show some
a hundred years ago
everybody had a parlor in their home or
in their church and a parlor was where
when somebody passed away they would let
the body rest for several days you'd go
to bed knowing that your loved one was
in the front part of your home in the
parlor or you'd go to church and you'd
walk past somebody who passed away and
you'd walk past you'd walk past
and then a
magazine it's like a ladies home journal
or southern living or a magazine like
that
and declared that we're no longer going
to have parlors in the house we're going
to have the living room
and now we all have living rooms in our
house
because we want death was not becoming
it wasn't something we wanted to talk
about we wanted to move past it's kind
of you know it's not fun to talk about
or think about and in the last hundred
years we've had this acceleration of
everything from plastic surgeries to the
botoxes to the fancy pants stuff to the
um here i wrote some things down here
this um
we outsource our dealings with the dead
right we don't have local butchers
anymore we go to the store and all the
meats already pre-packaged we don't even
get to see not only we don't see the
animal die but we don't see the butcher
actually cutting it off what still has a
bone on it we just buy it in a
cute little package
and
somebody else does all of the
hard dirty work for us
we don't deal with death anymore we call
somebody when somebody dies
somebody we don't know comes and takes
the body puts a sheet over it puts it in
a van and takes it down to the coroner's
office and then it gets taken over
by van nobody knows it's there over to
the funeral home and somebody who works
in the quote unquote funeral arts deals
with it all
and all this keeps us from seeing and
feeling bad for a while
but it also robs our bodies of a much
needed grieving process
we weren't designed to live
death-free lives we weren't designed to
live grief free lives we're designed to
go up and down and to have these seasons
of deep mourning that's how we heal
that's how we begin to open our eyes to
what's tomorrow going to look like
and so this article that came out was
talking about how
i'll just read it this woman um her name
was jess ma and her boyfriend died by
suicide in april and she immediately
emailed her team and said hey i'm gonna
be taking the next two days off
think about that
i'm gonna take a couple days off
and she's now a chief ceo of an
accounting firm and
uh of a software firm and she said
she couldn't sleep she was so enveloped
in grief her brain felt like it had shut
down she was so disenchanted with life
she said i was only operating at 10
capacity
until it hit her directly
we need to have a bigger conversation
about grief and i talk about this in the
book if
on most companies
if somebody if a direct family member
passes away you get three days
right you get four days
if an extended family member
you get a you can use sick leave to go
right and if you're an hourly worker
which millions and millions and millions
of people are your grief costs you
something directly you have to decide
how much hurt you can stomach because
every day you're not at work you're not
getting paid
the article goes on to say
millions around the world have gotten a
crash course in grief during the past
two years nearly one million americans
have died one million more americans
have died since the start of the
pandemic than would have otherwise been
expected obviously mostly from covet
other tragedies have marched on two with
lives lost to illness and accidents
some organizations are allowing workers
to take more time following a loss in
expanding grief policies to include
those who experience a miscarriage or
failed infertility treatment employees
are speaking up to
questioning policies that limit benefits
based on family relationships so what if
your mom and dad passed away if your
parents left you and your grandparents
raised you
might that not be considered right so
the whole thing is this this is a mess i
love the way she says this grief is this
weird nebulous blob that will take you
over when you least expect it
yes
absolutely
it this is incredible shout out and who
thought i'd ever say shout out to
goldman sachs but here i am goldman
sachs group last month implemented a new
20-day leave policy for those who suffer
miscarriage or stillbirth it also
increased time off from 5 to 20 days for
those who lose an immediate family
member classified as a partner a child
that's three weeks um
here's the thing
we can't escape being human
and i know there's all this cool stuff
like aging is a disease and we're gonna
solve it we're gonna live to be a
millionaire
you and me and those that we love are
going to pass away
the number of people who pass away
without a will is staggering and
mind-blowing why because we're all
going to pass away
the number of people who haven't talked
to each other
about hey what's life look like if one
of us isn't here who's going to take our
kids the number of people who don't have
that conversation is staggering it's
avoidant
and if you've not picked up one thing
from the show you've picked up this
our body as vander kulk says is keeping
the score we may not want to think about
it in our front of our brain but our
body knows
our body knows that our loved one is no
longer here and we can not look we can
avoid our body knows that this food
costs an animal it's life
our body knows that we're getting older
and we can wallpaper and duct tape and
get fancy filters on our instagram
cameras and do what kind of botox and
teeth we can do all the stuff
but this makes you an uh just it change
you to this anxious striving and stress
and chronic disconnection
so here's my challenge to you
write your obituary
write your obituary what do you want it
to say
spend a few minutes memento mori
understand you are going to die and so
are those that you love and this sounds
morbid and sad
this is one of the cornerstones
to healthy living to well living
understand this is coming for all of us
and when you can make peace
with this
is how this wraps up for all of us
then you are free to live
you're free to live
we live in a culture that has sanitized
all negative feelings all sadness all
hurt all
arrows pointing towards all of our
inevitable end
lean into that discomfort
lean into that discomfort because it's
when you lean into it that's where
wellness is
man
that sounds like a great book pitch
right
great book [ __ ]
hey delony let's talk about uh that
we're all going to die that too is in
the book
own your past change your future we'll
be right back
big secret
almost all of us can control our
thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them most people believe thoughts
randomly happen and that we have to give
rent-free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true
our world doesn't want you to know this
because they want the privilege of
owning your mind no more i want to teach
you how to take back your thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100
possible in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to mental
health and wellness that includes
learning how to reject harmful thoughts
and cultivate thoughts that move you
closer to who you want to be
and if you pre-order today you'll get
hundreds of dollars of free bonus items
so go to johndaloni.com to take the next
step towards wellness that's own your
past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back all right so this
is my confession
in my car right now i have three cds
i've got the all of the songs ever
by minor threat on a cd
i've got a no effect cd which is just an
old punk band
and i've got folklore by taylor swift
that's the truth that is the actual
truth that's in my in my car right now
and i'm driving my wife's prius if that
helps
just just putting that out there
and um jenna's back
in the studio
so i just looked at the studio and said
y'all come up with a song lyrics of the
day today
shocker
jenna came up with another taylor swift
song and it happens to be off the
folklore record
so america might weep today but here we
go
the song is the lakes by taylor swift
is it romantic how all my elegies
eulogize me
i'm not cut out for all these cynical
clones these hunters with cell phones
take me to the lakes where all the poets
went to die i don't belong in my beloved
neither do you
those
windmire peaks look like a perfect place
to cry i'm setting off but not without
my muse
what should be over burrowed under my
skin in heart-stopping waves of hurt
i've come too far to watch some
name-dropping sleaze tell me what my
words worth tell me what are my words
worth
take me to the lakes where all the poets
went to die i don't belong in my beloved
neither do you
those windermere peaks look like a
perfect place to cry i'm setting off but
not without my muse i want auroras and
sad pros i want to watch wisteria grow
right over my bare feet because i
haven't moved in years and i want you
right here a red rose grew out of ice
frozen ground with no one around to
tweet it while i bathe in cliffside
pools with my calamitous love and
insurmountable grief taylor swift bring
in the heat
way to go jenna way to go you everybody
we'll see you soon